[Music]
okay everybody watching make sure you
watch episode 5 of shmigadoon before you
watch this interview and come back
because i am so excited i'm gonna be
talking about this big episode
with kristin chenoweth aka the michael
jordan of the performing arts aka
mildred layton
how you doing today kristin um
first of all that's the best
introduction i've ever had at
all i love basketball so that you would
even rep
put me in the same sentence as michael
jordan and
i love you for that by the way did you
see the documentary the last dance
his i mean can something motivate you
more than that
i mean that's that's and i think you
have that effect on people that's why
i'm comparing it because it's
one of those things and you i love you
for that no but
i'm not just saying the kiss up like
what really like proves that you're
you're just have been doing it for so
long and in this episode of shmiga dune
when you do this big number of
tribulation there's so much going on and
when i was watching it my jaw was just
dropped especially because this is done
in
a one take can you kind of give some
kind of hope for us mere mortals like
how you go about remembering the
blocking looking at the camera
you know everything that goes into that
how do you do it
um i i hearken back to carrie
underwood's hit
jesus take the wheel
take it from my head i prayed
here's what i did i had 14 day
quarantine
i asked apple for a um what do you call
it elliptical
and i had apple tv this is this is not a
joke like i i know this was for apple
but i had apple tv
i did i watched 90 day fiance and i did
tribulation every day on the
elliptical because i was like not one
second is gonna be wasted on channel
with when it comes time for me to do
this thing
and that's the that's what i did that's
that's steve that is
the truth oh i love that when he's when
he
when he said he was going to do it in
one he knows me
seinfeld knows me so well he knows that
i'm always want to challenge
and that's how he got me okay
okay so speaking of that wanting a
challenge
you being this legend do you still feel
that
same drive to perfect the type of song
like this does that ever leave like you
ever just feel like i've done enough
like i don't need to give a hundred
do you always give 150 when you're doing
this kind of thing
gosh i love you so much thank you thank
you really truly
yes i care um there is a big part of me
the reason i think i love basketball and
the reason i think i love
the reference to michael jordan and i
loved kobe bryant so much
and i still can't believe he's no longer
here and i love russell westbrook my
dad's nickname for me
is chris brooke because i only know how
i don't know how to phone it in if i
could trust me there's been many times
that would have served me well
but i don't know how it's it's just not
a part of my dna so whenever that goes
away
is when i will retire oh that's not one
and i expect it from everybody else too
i expect it from everybody else too well
we all hope it never goes away and that
you don't retire but
um we still have more to look forward to
of mildred here
in this show can you before i let you go
can you give us a like a little tease of
what we might expect with the big finale
coming next week of sh
shmiga dune yes i think without giving
away too much
steve there is hope for
haters and people who lead with anger i
think there
is there can be evolution
and you know not for nothing but we did
shoot this at the height of the pandemic
prior vaccine in a foreign country
during an election
and if you don't think i didn't take
every emotion i had and put it into that
character
that the to the joker maniacal lips
to the too tight corset i just
i was uncomfortable well it's amazing
performance you're hearing it from her
all the stuff she puts into it if you're
crazy and watching this and haven't
watched the show already what are you
doing go watch it tell your friends
about it
it's on apple tv plus schmigadoon it's
incredible watch kristen kill it
as mildred thank you so much for joining
me today kristin i hope to talk to you
again one day in the future and keep
the dream the hoop dreams alive baby i
mean i can't believe you
put me in the same sentence as jordan
thank you so much i love him so much
and did you see in the documentary how
much he expected from his teammates
yes some some mistook that as as
arrogance or being too hard no no no
no he never asked anyone yep he never
asked someone to do something he
wouldn't do he wouldn't do it
goes by that too i love him i love i
love that
so much you've made my whole day
seriously you're the best thanks kristin
bye honey